theta is a woman knowingly working for a
monster he dreams of murdering his
family he kills people for art but what
really pushed theta over the edge was
that fourth prints are a dick when given
the opportunity simply refused to
subscribe to the new alt review for
regular Hunter hunter content uploaded
straight into his YouTube feed and that
theta thought was simply unforgivable
hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we're diving right
back into the succession wall art of
Hunter hunter to focus on a pair of
characters who are quite isolated from
the rest of the action at the moment yet
bound to play one of the biggest parts
within the entire contest those
characters being theta and sir I'd Nick
now I have briefly covered stride Nick
in previous videos but I really have not
lingered too much on theta and I'd like
to take the opportunity to do so today
because she is very very important as
theta is quite possibly the character in
the most unenviable position possible of
everyone currently aboard the black
whale 1 and is almost certainly going to
suffer a fate worse than death
whilst at the same time unleashing one
of the greatest monsters this series has
ever known upon the world so pretty damn
important for an arc specific character
who most of you probably forgot about
but that is hunter hunter for you but to
really get into this let's start by
understanding Thetas relationship to 4th
prince radnik and she is essentially one
of if not most his trusted bodyguards
she appears to command quite a bit of
respect or at least confidence in her
own ability from Surat Nick and they're
such theta is generally tasked with
taking care of any of his affairs that
do not have to do with his twisted
pursuit of art rather notably cirrhotic
has another subordinate who has the very
simple name of mark whom he uses to how
shall we put this gather materials for
his artworks ie lure women or young
people in general back to his hotel room
in order for Surat Nick to brutally
murder them and there may be contract
other artists to produce a work from
their remains in fact it's not
specifically known if theta is aware of
ceramics brutality in the arts but one
would have to think that working so
closely to him that she would have
discovered that he was a mass murderer
long long ago primarily due to the fact
that Sarandon makes no real effort to
hide the evidence of his endeavors so if
they towards walk into his quarters and
see yet another new piece of corpse art
chances are she's going to put two and
two together rather rapidly then again
to be fair sir I'd Nick may keep tater
at arm's length and not allow her into
his inner sanctum for a wide variety of
reasons one of which may be the
that she is a woman because that's
that's problematic right there he goes
right annex attitude towards women is
some less than chivalrous
say the least and raw general hatred to
say the most in fact Surat Nick himself
has admitted that the thing he hates
most in this world is a lying wench and
remember that fact because it's going to
be very important later but as for
data's mission upon introduction she and
several of sirenix are the bodyguards
were charged for taking the 289 hunter
exam and quite notably this was the
first exam instituted by the new
chairman Cheadle Yorkshire and so it
took on a very unique form to the
previous exams focusing far more on
psychological evaluations as well as
secretly using crop occur to weed out
potential spies and assassins but taking
this exam was a requirement to various
staff who were contracted to embark on
the voyage to the Dark Continent so as
one of Sonic's bodyguards theta had no
choice but to take the exam which she
and forest surroundings are the
bodyguards past and so weird with a
limited hunter's license to cover the
duties and duration of the Dark
Continent voyage following this theta
and her team were also tasked with
preparation for the succession war
acquiring specific knowledge of the
black whale one vessel including its
blueprints escape routes blind spots and
any other hidden secrets that the super
massive ship may be holding and they
went on to do that and for a while
everything seemed fine however roughly
two hours after the departure of the
vessel the Guardian n beasts of each
Prince made their presence known which
resulted in karateka a member of the
zodiacs and current bodyguard of 14th
prince mobile publicly announcing the
existence of den beasts through the
ship's emergency communication system an
action that would irrevocably change
this arc and this is because up until
this point Surat Nick was completely
unaware of the existence of men despite
his prominent position within the cocoon
Empire as well as the fact that two of
his siblings had already mastered the
art form to some degree in fact even
theta herself was an end-user prior to
the succession walk and has a grasp on
all of the major as well as many of the
advanced principles what we don't know
at this stage is if theta has developed
a heart to of her own
or she is only proficient in the general
use of men but I would say it is highly
likely that she has manifested at least
one hunter if only because she is
incredibly knowledgeable of nen and it
would seem a bit out of place if she had
not engaged in such a basic usage in any
case what matters more here is sera next
potential for nen because as things
would turn out he is a natural genius in
the art form however the combination of
ceramic and nen would also rapidly
signal an incredibly dire warning
the theta which was due to the idea that
nen manifests itself as a very personal
response to aura manipulation which can
be intended or subconscious and in
ceramics case it was entirely
subconscious at this stage but thanks to
the cedar and ceremony of the succession
war Saran Nick and his fellow princes
had been granted and then beasts each of
which was modeled after some sort of
desire personality trait or need of
their respective princes and upon
encountering Surat Nick's name beasts
for the first time theta immediately
knew what kind of man she was dealing
with as if she wasn't already aware
before but even then I don't think that
theta expected Sree Nick to be quite as
much of a monster as he would turn out
to be and at this point theta resolved
that Surat Nick was a man who should
never be allowed to acquire nen however
under the duress from his nan beast as
well as understandings radnyx
inquisitive nature theta was forced to
reveal her knowledge on the matter as
well as agreed to teach him now all of
this was agreed upon with theta
believing that she could taint Sur annex
training or at least impair him to the
point but he would never be able to
reach his true potential and then the
very thought of which terrified data
beyond or belief however this would turn
out to be unfortunately wishful thinking
and despite data's deliberate efforts to
stole Surat Nick his aptitude for nen
was so great that he easily began
mastering the basics and even some of
the more advanced applications within me
and days and a great example of this
would be the fact that shrine ik was
able to learn Gill in roughly half a day
now for some comparison to be fair gon
and killua were both able to master Kyo
in roughly that amount of time if not
slightly faster at the very comparison
of cirrhotic to two other natural nan
geniuses is further evidence of his
potential not only that but Sir Isaac
possesses a significantly higher degree
of maturity and analytical ability to
put it all to use as well which in my
mind makes him far far more terrifying
and either gone or kilowatt leaving
theta in a very very awkward position
and at one stage he even gets called out
as kropog uh had promised all of the
princes that he would be able to teach
their bodyguards nen in a two-week
period while theta had told Surat Nick
that it would take him six months
cirrhotic then asked theta if he can
trust her to which she obviously replies
yes but this response triggers to an
extend beast to activate and scratch
data's cheek with its barbs tongue which
theta I father sizes is part of a series
of conditions to activate its ultimate
ability and things continue to become
worse and worse for theta when she has
the Prince take a water divination test
to ascertain what natural type of news
so as to better produce a countermeasure
and she shockingly discovers that he is
a specialist making him nigh on
impossible to plan a response to due to
the versatile and unpredictable nature
of that typing and not only that but
Sara Nicholson managed to subconsciously
summon a second and Beast just because
that's what his natural genius allows
him to do
pushing theta into a corner where she
could see only one plan of action and
the general idea was to deceive Saran
akin to a state of zetsu the basic
principle that he did need to master
regardless but due to zetsu cutting off
the flow of aura data so this is a
perfect opportunity to dispel the tune
and base briefly as well as lower any
known defenses that the Prince could
possibly muster and shoot him square in
the head thus removing him from this
world as quickly as possible before he
became unstoppable so theta implemented
this and successfully shot sir anak in
the head thus saving the world or at
least that's the impression that I got
for a few precious moments because the
issue is not so much that's radnik had
subconsciously summoned a second and
beast but unknowingly to theta he was
also in the midst of crafting his first
heart suit the requirement for which was
that he'd be placed in a state of zetsu
and the effect of which was allowing him
to look 10 seconds into the future which
ultimately allowed him to change his
fate
following this ride next initial named
beast acted again warning theta then the
next time she lies to the prince she
would cease to be human and exactly what
this means is unknown at the time of
this recording but it would seem to
imply that this nen beast has an ability
that is able to transform people or
probably more specifically women or even
more specifically than that lying
wenches into some sort of abominable
existence that could further serve sir
I'd Nick that or they'd become a
lifeless husk or perhaps even given
sorry Nick's artistic nature they could
even become a new work for his
collection there's simply no way to know
at the moment but it is almost certain
that we will find out as theta is in by
far the worst position on the entire
ship she is a woman serving prince sir
I'd Nick and attempting to undermine him
making her something of a lying wench
sir I'd Nixon and beast and in abilities
given his personality have been catered
specifically to deal with this sort of
situation and data now has only one
chance remaining before she suffers his
full wrath so unless togarashi does that
thing he often does by subverting
expectations of blatant plot and
durability elements that he himself has
set up I'm really not feeling too
optimistic about data right now because
even if she isn't victim too
writings named beast the 4th prince has
also put out there that he would take
his sweet sweet time asking her why she
tried to kill him and obviously asking
in that context means brutally torturing
and given how he feels about women who
simply lied to him chances are he feels
just that little bit more intense
regarding those who tried to take his
life and that pretty much does it for
the unenviable situation of theta and
sir I'd Nick if you enjoyed this video
and the content this channel produced in
general and please do consider donating
to the new world review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon isn't
quite your style then please do leave
this video a like share or subscribe
because it also helps spot this channel
an incredible amount and if you'd like
to join the fun at any time then please
do head over to my desk or server where
a wide array of SHM an array takes place
on a daily basis and finally please do
comment with your thoughts on theta and
sir I'd Nick this has been the new old
review and I'll see you next time
[Music]
is Jing trying to find dawn as gone was
trying to find Jing no there's a thought
acquit and joy the idea that the story
of hunter hunter is just ever continuing
the cycle of the freaks family trying to
find their fathers or actually I guess
in the case of dawn
great-great-grandfather or something
maybe not even father at all he might be
an uncle or another relative of some
kind but you know that might make a lot
of sense because gone found Jing but
that's not quite the end of the freak
saga and then once Jing fines dawn well
then that dawn was looking for a distant
relative of I don't know let's call him
Jon freaks yeah and that way hunter
hunter just continues into all eternity
you add the milk before or after the
cereals what what kind of question is
this
definitely after the cereal and anyone
who does it before is an insane human
being if you could even call them that I
mean what possible benefit would one
derive from adding cereal after like you
punk whatever you're eating in it then
everything would just like float Wibbly
or is if you do the milk second it
cascades down the entirety of the cereal
coating it in brilliant milky glory and
some people might make the argument that
adding milk after risks making the
cereal at the bottom of the bowl a bit
soggy by the time you get to it my
response to that is simply eat better if
the cereal is super soggy by the time
you get to it then you are doing
something very very wrong and if you
purposely enjoy soggy cereal well that
is an entirely different discussion of
madness right there but to be honest I
think I've spent entirely too much time
discussing the intricacies of cereal on
this anime and manga based channel well
then maybe I can make a third channel
it's just entirely cereal based